so I don't know if I'm supposed to tell
you this or not but
um Tristan called me yeah and he said
that he privately went ahead and um took
care of the whole party that's very nice
but I won't let him do that Khloe
Kardashian shuts down Tristan Thompson's
kind gesture following news of his
latest infidelity what is in the media
is sort of things that we feel we need
to film because it's in a way unfair to
the viewers if they don't get to see
that we've shared so much about our
lives Chloe and Tristan's daughter true
turned four years old back in April I
cannot believe true is turning four I'm
entrusted in raising her and I take that
role so seriously and on the latest
episode of Hulu's the Kardashians fans
get an inside look at the over-the-top
cat themed bash which featured giant
balloon arches inflatable slides candy
Galore custom cookies mini Kitty cakes
real live kittens a slime station face
painting and a gorgeous three-tier cake
genuinely I cannot believe it so we
don't know the final price tag on the
event but it feels safe to say it was
pretty expensive get it perty
and Coco's Mama jerk Kris Jenner says
Chloe's ex who couldn't make it to the
party because he had a game wants to
pick up the tab and he said that he
privately went ahead and um took care of
the whole party no he's not scared the
whole party yeah he did that's nice but
I don't I won't let that happen yeah you
should he was so excited to do and I'm
so excited that I could do it all by
myself I know but you should let him do
that he wanted to do that for her for
his birthday that's very nice but I
won't let him do that yeah Chloe she's
not here for it I work really hard to do
elaborate things for true and I don't
need anyone's help of course this all
comes after Chloe got emotional on the
show opening up for the first time about
welcoming a second child with her ex
shortly after learning Tristan cheated
and had a baby with someone else
it was definitely very angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled I think that you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
not only you know what you see in the
press or whatever but what's really
happening behind the scenes Coco
revealed that she did an embryo transfer
to have a baby via surrogate just days
before news broke that the NBA star had
fathered another child with another
woman claiming that Tristan knew he was
having a baby with someone else but
still pushed Coco to move forward with
the surrogacy process it's just so close
I wouldn't want anyone to think I did
this after the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else of course Chloe and
Tristan split after his latest
infidelity and welcomed their newborn
son in July Tristan wants to be here so
I just figured why not let him come I'll
never get this moment back and as they
navigate life after the split a source
tells E.T that the X's are cordial and
they still support one another and want
to be the best parents which Echoes what
she told ET back in 2019
I'm just super happy and content and I'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and soul and true and I just
I'm having so much fun with her
[Music]